Andromeda galaxy is the closest galaxy
to our Milky Way
and it is the most distant object
visible to the naked eye
it is 2.5 million light years away which
means that when we see it we are seeing
the Galaxy as it was 2.5 million years
ago long before we were ever part of
this planet long before you came into
this world like a shooting star we read
this fact in one of your books about
space and you ask me how it's possible
to see something from so long ago even
if that thing is no longer there
I'm far from a physicist but I do my
best to explain the speed of light by
moving my hands back and forth in front
of my face as quickly as I can you are
unconvinced by this incoherent
explanation and how my arms are sore
so instead what I say is that when I
look at you it's like I'm looking at my
grandmother a woman you've never met but
whose Stardust is glimmering in your
eyes